hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we're going to be going over the
main character or protagonist of tokyo
revenges and the leader of tomen's
prestigious first division
our crybaby hero takamichi hanagaki
but before we get into takamichi make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
leave a like on the video as it really
helps out with pushing my content to a
bunch of new amazing people
but enough of that let's get into the
video
so takamichi as i've said is the
protagonist and main character of the
entire tokyo revenge's story so far
at the beginning of the series as a
young adult takamichi is 26 years old
and works a dead-end job in a dvd or
video rental store has extremely messy
unkept dark brown hair and wears very
plain clothes when compared to other
characters in the series
or even later on in one timeline when he
returns and is fully kitted out in a
dolce and gabanna outfit
keeping with the unkept style of
takamichi his flat or house is almost
completely filled with rubbish and old
food
because of the way takamichi's life had
turned out he had pretty much lost his
entire sense of direction
and didn't really know what his meaning
in life was as it really felt to him
like he was going nowhere
in his own words takamichi said that
since the age of 14 all he'd been was a
lazy good for nothing that only ran away
from all the confrontation or mistakes
he's made throughout his life
never standing up for himself or his
friends and constantly disappointing
loved people around him
but obviously this isn't the takamichi
that we know to grow and love throughout
this amazing series
this is the takamichi that had to be
thrusted by an unknown assailant onto
the train track
and killed so that the real protagonist
of the series could be reborn with an
actual
meaning and purpose for life one
afternoon
after his shift at work takamichi is
caught keen a vehicle by its owner
he runs off to the train station to get
away from the rich salaryman and head
back home
while standing there waiting for his
train takamichi thinks to himself
that he really hasn't got anywhere in
life he lives in a base up apartment
with thin walls and gets treated like an
absolute child
by a manager six years is younger he's
only ever had one girlfriend and this
was while he was in middle school
over 10 years earlier he says that he's
never had
anything perfect in life and he starts
to wonder where it all went wrong for
him
as he mentally hits rock bottom he is
also hit from behind by an unknown
assailant
shoving him into the lights of a quickly
approaching train
takamichi begins to have his life flash
before his eyes but instead of thinking
about his family members or close
friends
like anyone normally would he remembers
his ex-girlfriend
hinata tachibana who had died earlier
that same day
in an accident involving the tokyo manji
gang reminiscing more on these times he
realizes that middle school grade 2
was his heyday he was the number two of
a cool second-year delinquent group
the time whenever's only girlfriend was
flashing before his eyes
the moment takamichi starts to think of
his past with hina he somehow manages to
break time itself and is initially
gifted with the ability to move back
through time and space
12 years to the day we find that through
a vow or bond with naoto where there is
a specific desire and mutual agreement
to change the events of the past so that
the future is altered in a favorable
outcome
one can timely back and change things
but after one side of the mutual
agreement
is fulfilled and there is no longer any
kind of inclination for one side of the
party or that party has achieved its
goals
takamichi will be unable to travel back
through time and save anyone else who
might have not already been
saved this ability of time travel seems
exclusive to takamichi
and as i've said previously if both
parties have a mutual agreement to
change the past
and alter the future then takamichi will
be able to timely back with them to
where the origin of the unfavorable
outcome began as broken as his ability
to change the past may seem
there is actually some huge limitations
to it so that takamichi can't constantly
timeline back to the present timeline
him and the person he shook hands with
have to be living
if either of them die it makes takamishi
completely stuck
in that effective timeline and he will
have to relive his current life
unless he is unable to fix things so
that the person he leaps with doesn't
die
after countless events and moments
throughout a variety of amazing
arcs takamichi gradually moulds into a
completely different person
and becomes someone so valuable to the
quartoman members that sometimes i
forget he isn't even a founding member
himself
as the impact he has on its main members
like mikey draken
shifuyu and baji and a lot more make it
feel
as though he has been a lifelong friend
and the actions that he takes to protect
a loved one
is something that only an extremely
close friend or family member would ever
do
putting his life on the line and
fighting for someone else is a complete
parallel
to how he is introduced into the series
now
instead of being a coward and running
away from the first sight of
confrontation
just like when he keyed the rich salary
man's car he will now stand
up for himself even when facing
overwhelming odds of defeat
he will never refuse to back down this
conviction of his is spoken into
existence
during his battle with kyomasa when he
first stands up for himself
and says i'm not finished yet this isn't
enough to fix 12 years of being a lazy
good for nothing
i ran and ran ran and ran
i'm not going anywhere i got a damn good
reason not to
the tokyo manji gang kiyomasu
if you want to win you got no choice but
to kill me
and i am not going to lose this fight
where kiramasa
is one of the only fights throughout the
series in which takamichi actually
defeats an opponent himself
through sheer desperation after
constantly questioning himself
for the past 12 years and almost falling
into obscurity while listening to
draken's words of telling him to run
away with the girls to safety
pretty much telling takamichi to run
away and let one of his best friends
bleed out and die but this time he makes
the decision to finally change as a
person
there are other moments that may be much
more impactful but i truly believe that
this moment is one of the most
important throughout the series not just
for takamichi and his character building
in general but because if takamichi
hadn't faltered here
everything would have simply fallen into
the hands of the genius kasaki and mikey
would have immediately subsided into
darkness
becoming prone to the dark impulses he
possesses because of the news that
draken had passed away
but obviously this doesn't happen and
this is because of the pure endurance
that takamichi possesses
takamichi is definitely not a strong
fighter he lacks style and doesn't have
great movement so for sure has never
trained in some kind of martial arts
like mikey
normally takamichi would only be
considered as strong as any other
delinquent fodder in the gang
as he never really wins by himself but
he's slightly different if the
significance of the fight is
uncomparable
and could result in the death of a loved
one then takamichi's strength will often
scale to a level near that of his
opponents
possibly even higher if the story
compels it we his true strength does lie
as in the sheer endurance and
determination
that takamichi has when it comes to
brawling anyone who threatens his
perfect future
from a young age he's constantly stood
up to older kids
and has grown the strength to be able to
take blows from people twice his size
and even if he is knocked down he has
the utter determination
and durability to constantly get back up
to the point
where the person he is fighting is often
surprised by just how tough takamichi
truly is
throughout the series so far he has
taken a variety of blows from varying
weapons
such as being stabbed through the hand
with a knife or being shot in the foot
with a gun
and none of these injuries have really
made any effect yes
of course they would slow him down
eventually but in the heat of battle
when the blood is pumping it seems as
though they have no
real effect on him i honestly think
takamichi is an insanely human character
who like some people would have loved
the chance to reset his life from a
specific point and fix some of the
mistakes he made
and like any normal person initially
would he leaps at the opportunity to
save all of his friends and loved ones
but what makes him special to me and i
think a lot of other readers and now
watches of the show
is his determination to never give up
this anime trope that is constantly used
in every single action-based anime
or fighting story can become a little
bit overused like as an example fairy
tale i think
overuses this trope but with tokyo
revenges and takamichi it feels as
though the times that he does never give
up
are the moments that matter more than
anything because as we all know as
readers and watches
are the outcomes that are destined to
happen and often takamichi is forced
into a corner
when trying to fix these but never when
times are tough
does he seem to give up or be knocked
down against all
odds takamichi always seems to come out
on top never giving up on his original
goal of changing the last 12 years of
his lazy
good for nothing life but as you know i
love the tokyo avengers series and
takamichi hanakake is definitely one of
the best protagonists i've seen
and he has some of the best character
building throughout this series
so if you haven't picked up the manga
yet or even begun the anime i recommend
that you do both for sure as you
definitely won't regret it
and if you have enjoyed my video on
takamichi hanagaki then make sure you
hit that like button and leave a comment
down below with who you'd like me to go
over next and take your avengers
i've also done some other character
showcases so if you guys want you can
check those out here
and if you guys are new around here and
want to keep up to date with the latest
tokyo revenge's jiu jitsu guys in
one piece one punch man black clover and
more anime content then be sure to hit
that subscribe button and ring that bell
but anyway for now spin your
professional degenerate diavolo and i'll
see you all in a bit
[Music]
bye
you